the world has ended and what's left
isn't pretty
a deadly virus called h5g9 or the sick
for short has all but destroyed humanity
and the remaining population is
struggling to survive they are also
struggling to make sense of these
strange human animal hybrid babies that
have started turning up in the decade
after the apocalyptic plague
some like the dangerous last men seek to
hunt the hybrids down
others take a more benevolent approach
choosing to save and
shelter the poor kids no one seems to
know what's really going on
such is the premise of netflix's
critically acclaimed sweet tooth a
fantasy drama that's based on jeff
lemire's comic book of the same name
its story focuses on the adventures of a
human deer hybrid called gus
and his adult friend tommy shepard they
spend the first season of the show
traveling around and getting in all
sorts of trouble and by the time the
final episode ends it's clear just how
many secrets and dangers they're up
against
let's take a look at the exciting ending
of sweet tooth season one
the whole season has been a never-ending
series of discoveries for gus who
started the show with barely any
knowledge of the world
dangerous as they've been his travels
with jeopard have often had an air of
excitement and even positivity
by the end of the season however the
poor kid's world has come crashing down
in virtually every possible way
he now knows that he's actually a
genetic experiment and that his supposed
biological parents birdie and pubba
were actually affiliated with the
laboratory where genetic unit series
1 gus in other words was created of
course the show's not happy with just
upending poor gus's sense of self and
turning his childlike wonder into shock
and sadness
general abbott's last men also take over
amy's preserve and capture its hybrid
children
[Music]
what is that thing one of them
the kids are now prisoners and subject
to nasty experiments by the conflicted
dr
singh who doesn't really like what he's
doing but remains desperate to find a
cure for the sick
despite all this awfulness there is a
silver lining
gus seems quite happy to find other
hybrids and his ability to speak
saves him from the scalpel besides a
cliffhanger at the end of the episode
makes it pretty clear that amy and
shepard are gearing up for the mother of
all daring rescue operations
speaking of shepard the season finale is
called big man and sure enough it puts
tommy jeopard and his past trauma front
and
center through a combination of
flashbacks and expository dialogue we
learned that when his wife gave birth
amidst the apocalyptic chaos
jeopard panicked and ran away from her
and their child when he saw that the
baby was a human sheep hybrid
he never found either of them again and
his cowardice and
loss weigh heavily on him as such part
of his decision to help gus is an
attempt to redeem his past mistakes
i wasn't afraid of him
i was afraid of me it's all very tragic
and gets even more so when the last men
ruin the moment by shooting shepard
fortunately amy is able to rescue him
before he succumbs to the injury
like everyone else who's not affiliated
with the last men and general abbott's
nefarious plot to use a cure for the
sick to grab
even more power bear has a battled time
in the ending of sweet tooth season one
in her case though it's mainly because
viewers find out how awful her life has
been
as with jeppard we learn a whole bunch
of her backstory starting with her real
name
becky walker and the reason she ended up
with the animal army
bear lost her parents to the sick had
her hybrid little sister taken away and
wandered around until she met tiger and
started her new life
fortunately the audience learns that
wendy is bear's long-lost sister so
there's hope for happiness yet
bear is also responsible for the final
reveal of the season when her attempts
to tinker with a satellite phone finally
connect her to a station in alaska
where a very surprised birdie answers
the phone with gus's mother still alive
it's pretty clear that the potential
sweet tooth season 2 just gained a very
powerful and determined player
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one